today I'm announcing that I terminated
Eddie Johnson's employment as
superintendent the Chicago Police
Department for cause effective
immediately upon reviewing the materials
as to Eddie Johnson of the Inspector
General's ongoing investigation
regarding the events of October 16th and
early morning hours of October 17th and
thereafter it has become clear that mr.
Johnson engaged in a series of actions
that are intolerable for any leader in a
position of trust
particularly the head of the Chicago
Police Department this is obviously not
a decision that I entered into lightly
however the circumstances demanded these
actions first the finding for the of the
inspector general's report regarding mr.
Johnson which I recently reviewed makes
clear that Eddie Johnson engage in
conduct that is not only unbecoming
but demonstrated a series of ethical
lapses and flawed decision-making that
is inconsistent with having the
privilege of leading the Chicago Police
Department
second Johnson intentionally misled the
public in a press conference he called
on October 17 2019 he was not caught off
guard and he had plenty of time to
choose his words and a choice he made
was to communicated narrative replete
with false statements all seemingly
intended to hide the true nature of his
conduct from the evening before finally
just like with the public Eddie Johnson
intentionally lied to me several times
even when I challenged him about the
narrative that he shared with me he
maintained that he was telling the truth
I now know definitively that he was not
had i known these facts at the time I
would have relieved him of his duties as
superintendent then and there mr.
Johnson failed the hard-working members
of the Chicago Police Department he
intentionally misled the people of
Chicago and he intentionally misled me
none of that is acceptable
this moment needs to be a turning point
for the Chicago Police Department the
way things are done in this city as for
the department yesterday today and
tomorrow has to be about culture change
that must start at the top that hard but
important work is impossible without
strong leadership focus on integrity
honesty legitimacy and accountability
the old Chicago Way must give way to the
new reality ethical leadership integrity
accountability legitimacy and yes
honesty
must be the hallmarks of city government
well a lies a lie he told me something
that happened that night that turned out
to be fundamentally different than what
he had portrayed to me and what he
portrayed to members of the public they
go let me go back here marry me yes I
met with them this morning and relieved
him of his responsibilities as police
superintendent accepting
you